faire un excellent massy bonjour bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
dans la matinale de rtl france alors
treize membres de l'union européenne
dénonce donc une nouvelle loi hongroise
1 jugé discriminatoire pour la
communauté lgbt
mais que dit précisément cette loi alors
c'est une loi qui a pour but avant toute
chose d'augmenter la criminalisation de
la pédophilie
il ya eu un scandale il ya un an d'un
diplomate hongrois qui a été dont on a
découvert dans l'ordinateur d'aider des
fichiers de pédopornographie et il a été
condamné de manière assez légères
concrètement il a eu une grosse amende
et donc ça ça fait un scandale et après
que le parti nationaliste mais razengues
qui est fait toute une campagne anti
anti pédophilie en disant que c'est pas
possible que que la pédophilie soient
aussi peut condamner le gouvernement a
décidé de réagir le parti victor obama
proposait donc cette modification de la
loi qui qui chercha à condamner plus
lourdement donc en en que j'ai noté donc
ça cherche surtout à durcir les peines
pour les actes commis à l'encontre des
enfants de moins de 12 ans commis par
des fonctionnaires commis avec
harcèlement ou violence commis par des
récidivistes
ça vise aussi à empêcher donc les les
les pédophiles condamnés à pouvoir
travailler dans des secteurs où il ya
des enfants et c'est ce qui fait débat
ce qui fait surtout des bas c'est que
dans cette fois il ya aussi un autre
aspect de la protection de l'enfance qui
concerne donc la toute la propagande
en rapport avec les sexualités qui ne
sont pas faits d'une manière générale la
sexualité et c'est de ne pas exposer les
enfants là la sexualité en particulier
homosexuels et alors c'est là que ça
fait débat puisque les le lobby lgbt est
très actif sur la sexualisation des
discours à l'égard des enfants et ça ça
pourrait mettre un coup d'arrêt comment
vivent les condamnations à des pays
européens comment ces condamnations sont
elles perçues en hongrie ben c'est
quelque chose qui pour lectorat de
lecteurs au ban du moins est quelque
chose de coloré et est aujourd'hui tout
à fait compréhensible parce qu'ils sont
habitués
habitué à être attaqué en permanence
pour tous et en particulier pour des
sujets de bon sens ou de défense de nos
valeurs sociétales le l'union européenne
est assimilé au lot via gvt pour
beaucoup en hongrie et je crois que la
réaction de van der leyen par exemple et
des autorités de bruxelles lors donne
raison
c'est à dire que lorsqu on assimile les
théories et les visions du monde lgbt
aux valeurs européennes
c'est quelque chose qui est irrecevable
pour la hongrie donc cesser c'est hélas
pas surprenant mais c'est pas du tout
pris au sérieux en fait on voit bien que
pour certains politiciens occidentaux
ces moyens faire feu de tout bois c'est
à dire que tout est bon pour attaquer la
hongrie puisqu'il puisque séance est un
peu l'épouvantail qu'on adore montrer
alors qu'en réalité il n'ya aucune
provocation de la part de l'onglet les
provocations
c'est plutôt celle du lobby lgbt qui
cherche à faire main basse sur les
enfants on le voit très bien dans dans
tous les pays occidentaux et le fait que
la hongrie met simplement des mesures
qui permettent de juguler ces velléités
forcément c'est mal pris mais l'anglais
ne cédera pas là-dessus ce que ça veut
dire pour bien comprendre c'est ça c'est
que
ce qui est interdit c'est la promotion
de la sexualité homosexuelle pour les
mineurs c'est ce que dit cette loie
finalement exactement c'est un des
aspects de l une des modifications de la
loi
donc concrètement ça va probablement se
traduire par des sigles jeu c'est peut
être des cibles moins de 18 ans par
exemple dans des séries où il ya des
actes homosexuels montrer ce que
aujourd'hui même dans des séries grand
public il ya il ya des actes sexuels ont
ce genre de choses on va voir comment ce
passe l'application évidemment puisqu'il
ya la loi et l'esprit de la loi
on verra comment gérera sa le conseil de
l'odieux de l'audiovisuel mais ce qui ce
qui est certain c'est que il y aura une
attention particulière portée sur la le
montage et la propagation de la
sexualité homosexuelle en particulier
parce que vous nous disiez cas là bas
c'était une loi contre la pédophilie ce
qui est autre chose que la question de
l'homosexualité quelle est la situation
des personnes aujourd'hui homosexuels en
hongrie est ce qu'il ya effectivement
des discriminations qui sont relayés par
exemple par la presse il n'ya aucune
discrimination
toutes les personnes homosexuelles ou et
wayan d'une une orientation sexuelle qui
concerne les adultes consentants donc
aucun problème en gris aucun il suffit
de venir à budapest pour s'en convaincre
je dirais même qu'il ya plus de chance
pour une personne dite à gvt d'être
agressés en france qu'en hongrie puisque
les populations ne sont pas tout à fait
les mêmes
non pas tout à fait même attitude par
rapport à ces gens là la hongrie a
toujours été un pays très tolérants à
l'égard des individus
voilà simplement il ya des choses qui
relèvent des normes sociales et
sociétales et ça ça n'a pas vocation à
changer dans un dans un pays qui n'a pas
du tout la même approche de ces
questions pour des raisons historiques
donc non il n'y a aucun problème pour
l'ailé pour les personnes pour le
personnes gbt merci beaucoup faire un
calme assis d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je le rappelle vous êtes
rédacteur en chef du vice grave poste